what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to explain every warmer titan in
the history of attack on titan
ranging from nearly 2 000 years ago all
the way up to the present day of the
series
as we found out in season 4 the
warhammer has a unique ability to create
basically anything it wants out of titan
hardening
as well as being able to remotely
control the titan from inside a crystal
for the warhammer titans that we
probably know i'll be explaining the
backstory of that user
in addition to what makes their titan
unique and for the other warhammers
throughout history
i'll be commenting on their designs plus
giving a few theories about a couple of
them
be sure to like subscribe if you want to
see more videos like this and let me
know in the comments which titan you
think i should cover next
okay so the first warmer titan on this
list is lara tiber
who was a member of the prestigious
tiber family for at least a few hundred
years
the tiber family had exclusive
possession of the warhammer titan
with lara being the final one of them to
have it since the events of the great
titan war
their family secretly ruled mali from
the shadows with her older brother
willie being the leader of their clan on
her first appearance in the series
she stood quietly in the background
before dishing out a plate for her
nephew
and at the time many viewers either
didn't notice her or just assumed she
was the maid
as time progressed we got a small hint
that she might be important
as she was the only family member that
willie brought to the declaration of war
yeah in hindsight i think she should
have stayed home lara's warhammer titan
had a thin shell of hardening covering
his body
but his eyes and mouth was still partly
visible thanks to the stripy design that
it had in those
areas it had an interesting semi-circle
pattern on both sides of its neck
and its physicality was like a skinnier
version of the attack titan
pique stated that the tibers never used
their titan against an enemy nation
meaning that lara's battle with erin was
the first ever real fight she had
that makes it even more impressive that
she was able to create at least
seven different weapons or structures
during their battle with the best for me
being the crossbow or the giant pillar
in a kind of ironic twist lara's final
words were her asking aaron if he had
any final words
and yeah she was eaten about 10 minutes
after that the next warhammer titan is
none other than eren yeager
who mercilessly stole the power after
using porco as a nutcracker
unlike his predecessor aaron does not
come from a noble bloodline
and was just a regular kid born within
the walls of parodies island who had a
burning desire to see the outside world
when he was 10 years old the warriors of
mali launched their attack on paradise
with aaron's mother being eaten by a
titan in the process
on that same day aaron's father grisha
used the power of his attack titan to
steal the founding titan from the royal
family
grisha would then forcibly give these
abilities to his son with aaron not
realizing that he had titan powers
until years later at 19 years old aaron
infiltrated mali by himself
going undercover as a wounded aldean
soldier his primary goal was to collect
his half-brother zeke and bring him back
to paris island
but along the way he would do to marley
what was done to him as a child
using the power of his attack titan
aaron would kill willie tiber
malian military generals innocent
citizens of liberio
and politicians from around the world
his final victim was lara tiber
as he would use the biting strength of
poco's jaw titan to forcibly destroy the
crystal that lara was in
by drinking the contents of her spine
aaron inherited the warhammer titan
and is the first character we know to
have three titan shifters in one body
aaron's warhammer titan has not yet
appeared in the anime so pause the video
now if you're an anime only
as from this point on i will be talking
about spoilers as usual i would
encourage you to come back to this video
once the final season is over
but until then you probably don't want
to continue with that said
eren's warmer titan looks exactly the
same as his regular titan form
as he seemingly chose not to use his new
power to create a white shell around his
skin
he definitely could have done this if he
had the desire to do so but i guess you
shouldn't fix what's not broken
even without the typical warhammer titan
look aaron was very proficient with this
power
as he created massive spikes out of the
ground that even pierced through the
armored titan
this however was not the first time he
had used this power as his previous
achievements include busting himself out
of his underground cell
and then sealing off his escape route so
that no one could follow him
moving on we're going to talk about the
designs of the other warhammer titans
throughout history
including a theory i have that i think
makes perfect sense these titans all
made appearances in the final arc of
attack on titan
so without further ado let's start with
the robocop warhammer titan
this one has the sturdiest looking
helmet of all the warhammer titans out
there
but the mouth is completely uncovered
which is a feature that you don't
normally see with this specific titan
it has three horizontal slits around the
eye area but beyond that the rest of his
body is pretty standard as far as warmer
titans go
like i said the design is possibly
inspired by robocop i mean that's the
thing that came to my mind
but whether it is or isn't it still
looks awesome we first saw this titan
when it manifested a bow and arrow
and during that same bone arrow scene
there were a bunch of other warhammer
titans with unique designs
this one here had flowing hair coming
out the back which is not something you
typically see from a warhammer titan
and these two here had headgear that
sort of reminded me of chainmail armor
or
executioner style headgear like i don't
know
it has a medieval feel to it for most of
the titans in that particular scene we
don't know which era they came from
but i can tell you a theory that i have
about this warmer titan right here
with the circular markings on his face
remember the anime already confirmed
that the white shell that covers most
warhammer titans
is made from the same hardening that
they use for their weapons that means
they must have control over how their
shell looks
in the same way they have control over
their other creations you're probably
wondering why i'm bringing this up
and to get straight to it my theory is
that this draw titan right here
was potentially a close friend of this
warhammer titan
their designs are so similar that what
i'm thinking is
the draw titan inherited this strange
design and then when the warhammer titan
got their titan
they decided to mould their armor so it
matched their friend i would say though
that these two cannot be related by
blood
because all of the nine titans were held
by different families so the type of
family had the warhammer
and a separate unknown family had the
draw so i'm thinking that the draw just
happened to get this design
and then the warhammer kind of emulated
it to match their their body essentially
anyway up next we have this panel here
and there are two specific warhammers
that i want to point out
i suspect that this warhammer in the
back is the first weimar titan to ever
exist
as in chapter 122 we saw pretty much the
first iteration of every titan
starting with the first founding titan
and then later in the chapter we see the
remaining eight in a brief panel
its notable features include his hair
the lines around his eyes and mouth
and the lines around his stomach area
which is not something that we've seen
like this before
this is reminiscent of lara typer's
design as she did have lines around her
eyes and mouth as well
but i mean the first warhammer did take
it a step further by having it around
this area
the other one i wanted to point out was
this warhammer standing on top of rhino
primarily because it created a scythe
out of titan hardening
that is not a weapon i've seen any other
wilma titan make so
maybe just a quick theory on that is
that during the great titan war
maybe this guy was like an executioner
where he would go around like
decapitating other uh titan shifters
during battle
who know that he's just a guest but uh
this was a very specific weapon choice
in chapter 135 we saw a few more
interesting warmer titans
with this one here being especially
freaky its mouth has a partition where
there is just bare flesh
and the shell in the center of its
forehead forms this weird triangle
over here when we look in the background
we can see the cloaked warhammer titan
which seemingly has a flexible cloak
draped over its body
thanks to lara tiber's whips we already
knew that the warhammer could make
bendable titan hardening
and this one here used that ability to
full effect by giving themselves a nice
titan dressing gown
the final warhammers that i thought were
worth mentioning include this one that
attacked reiner as it had an interesting
pattern on the front and back of his
head
over here we have a unique titan whose
entire face was partially covered in
hardening this one was funny because the
design is pretty cool on the surface
but at the same time it just looks so
uncomfortable like many of the other
warhammer titans i would imagine that
his vision is at least partially blocked
but for some reason the warmer titans
don't seem to mind having designs that
block
large portions of their eyes in the
comments below let me know which was
your favorite warhammer titan design
and also tell me which titan shifter you
want to see next be sure to drop a like
as it does up out the video
and until the next one peace out